let's dive into Italy yeah this kind of
All Began because Jordan had already
been doing this exact specific trip to
Italy for many years yes solo by
yourself often solo yeah oh so who who
went with you uh there have been various
people who joined me for certain legs
Stanley Tucci you know this is it's
generally structured as a road trip from
point A to point B so sometimes if I
have a friend that's local to one area
they'll join me for a short portion oh
often local by Design deliberately local
but but the same itinerary usually it
started in Florence OR Firenze and Drive
South to Naples it did it did vary
Napoli yeah for some reason the north to
south progression always felt the most
natural to me
um but no I I've experimented with
different cities at certain times but I
found my favorites and decided to go
back to those over and over again and
you know it's worth noting that when we
were first planning our show
there was there were some opinions about
how we should structure it and one of
the opinions was we should just stay in
Rome right do everything out of Rome
which immediately was like discouraging
for me because I knew that for me the
great part of Italy was experiencing all
these different places by virtue of a
road trip but I guess I felt maybe it
wasn't practical for a TV production but
in the end you guys made the actual
decision to do it that way and I think
that you have said no if we had just
stayed in Rome of course not but I felt
like even throughout the trip there were
times where I felt self-conscious
because through my own
um opinion we would go to a certain city
like Nate yeah I feel like there was
some question about should we go to
Naples because it was a bit out of the
way and I felt this pressure that we
better get something good in Naples
because that was also toward the end of
the trip and people were tired and it
was I'll use the word grueling it was a
big grueling packing up there were many
places where we stayed for one night got
there late at night packed up the next
morning filming all yeah and I I feel
like there were some people that were
kind of rolling their eyes at going to
Naples and so like I said I just felt
this pressure and then I don't think
anyone in this no no no no no but we do
acknowledge that there was there was
this overall sentiment like wow we're
really traveling a lot and this is
really tiresome it was growing yeah and
I also don't remember wanting to stay in
Rome I I think that was Rome it was
never the plan
that was a suggestion is part of my trip
Rome was part of our trip but it
certainly wasn't a home base we did not
have a home base I I thought we we were
going to go to India that yes exactly
I mean we've planned this whole thing uh
in like two weeks yeah and it was
the whole idea was to do your road trip
like that the particularness of it is
what was attractive I'm happy that in a
last minute situation you had at least a
starting foundation for yes for what the
trip could be and that's what it was I
haven't heard you guys talk about
previously the fact that this was a last
minute trip because India fell through
yes and um you know for years I
suspected that maybe you know once the
um Conan without border series started I
suspected maybe one day Italy will
happen right yeah um and I remember the
one thing you were lying in wait
it's a natural assumption
you were slipping Italy Flyers office
doors sorry go ahead no the one thing
about suspecting that this may happen
one day that was in my head is I hope
it's in summer or spring the beautiful
time I mean even fall as long as it's
not winter it was in my mind because I
had been to Italy in winter and it and
it was not as rewarding and um it was
February and it was Winter it was the
one time of year where uh you wouldn't
necessarily want to go that said
um Italy I think it's yeah it turns out
it worked and I don't think it's
honestly any worse uh for for having
that there was like rain and you know we
had a umbrellas whatever not not a big
deal this was my thought process okay
yeah you guys called me into at Conan's
office and said we're going to Italy and
uh the first thought in my head was I
can't believe it has to be winter right
and that's it that was my thought well
we opened your eyes there's a smell to
the flowers and Tuscany and Springtime
is that you completely missed right
we'll have to go I don't know this
species of Flora specifically I can't
say that it was Citrus but it's it's
wonderful okay all right
well now the whole Trip's ruined yeah
yeah so we just jumped on your Trail and
that included Naples like that was a big
part of it yeah once we were there was a
moment in the we were shooting in a
coffee shop yes and Conan was uh
performing well yes and hilariously
right and in that moment the thought in
my head was okay we
and this was kind of on the at the
Forefront of neapolitan pizza being uh
being exported everywhere so we got I
feel like we were part of a movement
yeah yeah that that we shot something at
the pizza place but
that was just like we edited it and
we're like oh okay for anyone that
doesn't know I'm often kept in the dark
I think By Design so as not to hear any
potentially negative feedback I might
assume I don't know why I'm kept in the
dark but I don't I don't know often see
these things I don't often see these
things until they're screened for an
audience okay um so I'm not in on the
post-production process right while
they're being shot I guess you'd say I
had a have a certain amount of control
in what I choose to say sure how I might
choose to subtly steer as we're shooting
but then after that I have zero control
it sounds like a gripe so no I'm just no
you're I I feel did you have notes on
this one that you gave us because I
previously had worked with you on a
remote where you did have some follow-up
notes did I yes which remote was that
um we went and did a coffee tasting wow
and there was some moment where I think
you had maybe misstated the milliliters
oh that's required sure
um
needed to clear that up and I was like
no
although you guys started uh started
this experience with your customary uh
saying that if anything needs to be
taken out just let us know no problem
and I'm here to say that that's not true
I haven't requested this in the past and
I've been flat out till noon
not in the Italy show but there was
another remote Matt O'Brien it was the
remote where I was coming in late yeah
and uh there was a scene where I I
removed my shirt yes and I I asked Matt
O'Brien uh to remove that and he just
said no I said Remember the one time
I've never asked for anything to be
removed I never I know I never what were
you on top in retrospect maybe it was an
unreasonable request but um nevertheless
I learned the lesson that when you offer
to take things out I I it's really an
empty all right of course of course well
if you're gonna get half naked yeah I
mean well why did you want that taken
out yeah you know I don't I maybe I just
I think looking back you'll be pleased
yes your children you have a very nice
body you know thank you for that thank
you Phil I appreciate that that's why I
brought it up
you did have to so you did have to take
your shirt off again in fact a lot of
them and your pants shirt and pants on
the Italy
yes in Florence naked nude this is
Jordan
I think a pose would be appropriate
hitchhiking you're hitching a ride and
you're naked this is called naked man
looking for a ride
can give me one of these
that's good
this is called
mentally ill manatee
there's no laughing here please
see here the deadness in the eyes
there's no soul the man has no soul
there's just nothing in there and then
legs sort of like a frog
but a frog gets very sickly been like
excuse me because you told me the best
excuse me excuse me models
there's one last pose if you could face
that way
and then you look back with a jaunty
look as if to say check out my butt
let me give us a thumbs up
we tell you in advance that you were
gonna have to do that
um I don't uh I don't yeah maybe I I
don't remember the conversation but uh I
think other staircase up to the when I
handed you the dance Bells yeah put this
on there was a real nude model there
yeah as we walked in and uh Ruthie I
guess who is with us yes who's doing yes
oh yes yes is she um I guess had not
initially seen that naked man okay and
she saw me wearing a robe and then she
went away to do something and she came
back and she saw um the man's genitalia
and was shocked quickly she thought she
quickly thought it was me and uh she was
quite shocked and she immediately
tweeted about it
under the Team Cocoa bag so why didn't
you request uh
to have that removed we're fully nude as
you said maybe I was encouraged by the
success of the first time okay there you
go retroactively wow did you feel you
had to prepare your body in any way for
this I mean I prepare my body regardless
all right I don't need anything you're
always ready I'm ready are you ready
right now if we asked for it I mean if
it needs to happen if I feel that it's
Justified
let's go bottomless you've drunk on time
yes fully nude
I'm not prepared
well we started we could go
chronologically we started in Florence
yes
um that was where the nude art class was
we also walked we walked through
Florence that was the rainy day I
remember it was it was a little cold I'm
with you Jordan yeah it's a chilly day
and we found Conan found a Pinocchio uh
I don't know how to describe it it was
sort of a wooden cut out yeah you put
your face in you put your face in to
become Pinocchio they have Pinocchio
stores in Italy where you can just go
they specialize in Pinocchio's yeah toys
well Pinocchio was written by Carlo
collodi who lived here so they're very
proud of it Conan saw this cut out and
um it wanted to humiliate Jordan by
making him sit in it oh look
this is absolutely fantastic if I
purchase this would you be willing
to walk around in this all while you're
in the office I swear I'll pay you extra
money
[Laughter]
and then we of course purchased this big
piece of wood it's in this building
right now by the way okay that was my
that was gonna be my question so let me
remember I had to carry it around I
think all of Italy
physically carrying yeah that was the
very first day oh first day we got that
Pinocchio it weighed around 40. it was
Heavy yeah it was and we don't have a
normal wood you know crew with product
people and this and that so yes
[Music]
it was a classic thing where we were
laughing so hard at you in that
Pinocchio thing that we're like oh my
God we've got to buy it in Brick because
we're gonna use it again
yeah never used it again and then porch
Lemmy every morning I think would
probably be like should I bring the
Pinocchio yeah yeah bring it Gotta Have
It oh I remember going the train with
him I have a photo of you one of the
train stations I have very little memory
of shooting with it in Florence but I
have a lot of memories carrying it
around
the cumbersome the awful thing is a lot
of times you'll say in the morning do I
bring the blood yeah and then we go and
we're all like well no we're not gonna
but then it's like just in case the one
time don't bring the Pinocchio that will
be the day
where's the Pinocchio I need it now yeah
and then you you mentioned Jordan that
this was a road trip
um so we did honor that part of it and
uh rented a Fiat cinquecento which is is
that that's the car that you always
drive if I can get it yeah when we rent
a car it really especially when you're
talking about a road trip you want to
get a good car that could make or break
you don't want like a Fiat Panda okay
that is a disgusting
so much of your road trip is in the car
so many of your pictures involve the car
if you have a Fiat Panda that's a bad
day okay and a lot of times I have to
make like really intricate arrangements
with the rental car to make sure I get a
cinquecento which by the way to to the
rental car establishment is not anything
special it's it's probably their lower
lowest price
yes I want that authenticity I want that
uh historical Beauty so we got a vintage
one 1962. yeah
um which was Tiny it was really tiny
yeah adorable I've been in small cars in
my life this is the smallest car I've
ever been in
I don't think it's safe it doesn't
clearly have airbags
it has a wind bag
yeah that was a that was a good segment
it was because the car broke down it
actually broke down yeah yeah and you
had trouble driving it as I recall yeah
it would stall it would sell frequently
oh maybe the car was fine it was all an
operator error certainly possible but
yeah that was a crazy I remember
starting that morning and and you would
start in Florence and then drive down
through Tuscany and end up in Cortona
um and we really filmed you that whole
way
following you in that little car that
was a great day for whatever reason that
same day we had a vest we rented a Vespa
which I think this is a b-roll yes I
think we had a drone that was the
earlier days where we didn't always have
a drone that was like a special thing
that was only a second I think we only
used one oh no no we used a few shots
there was a shot of the cinquecento
driving at the end of that uh particular
segment and then there was I think one
shot of the Vespa and the end credits
Conan and I going across the bridge yes
so we could probably spend eight hours
on that yeah it uh there was a lot of
time but that was a fun day
um you know behind the scenes you're
working you're working but then there
were these isolated moments of elation
at least for me and there was one where
um I was running the Vespa Conan was on
back it was this like Scenic bridge and
you kind of step outside the experience
and you say like wow this is amazing
um so yeah that that one day we had the
cinquecento and the vasova and it was it
was a fun day that was a long day that
was a long day that was not a fun day
you're really interesting yeah yeah
different experience you're leaving out
two other segments we did traffic
then the wine tasting yes and then we
were all so exhausted we went to your
favorite restaurant oh my gosh yes that
was Valentine's Day yeah I remember that
that was Valentine's Day and so we were
so exhausted we set two cameras on
sticks to shoot you two having a meal
and we just went in the other room there
were no cameramen uh presents no for
that dinner it was It was kind of on
autopilot we came in every 20 minutes
no we hadn't we were non-stop that whole
day that was another now as I think
about it there was as I was eating
dinner with Conan I was sensing I
remember that I had pressure on no I
felt pressure again
because he seemed exhausted and I had
this pressure like okay something good
better come out of this dinner and
um then I think it did I was that's one
of my favorites from that shirt yeah it
was one of the best segments and we were
we had nothing to do we weren't even
paying attention so it makes me think no
we should have just let him know
and we could have enjoyed Italy we could
go to museums no I know you did mention
Sweeney the Truffle hunting remote which
is
weirdly one of my favorite memories from
that trip oh yeah we were so excited
about the setup of it and you know we
got these real truffle hunters and
truffle hunting dogs and then we went
out in the countryside and almost
immediately Conan sniffed out he thought
that they were planting the truffles in
advance of us finding them wait
what's this you found another one yeah
look at this they just found another one
just get in here
I strongly suspect these guys because
they knew we were coming
hid these people because they're finding
them very easily
don't you think so I concur they keep
going
we're barely even looking for them
because they were you know they would
they would find one and it was like not
not very deep beneath the soil and kind
of brush it off price tag on it right it
was like a chill child's Easter egg hunt
exactly it was pretty light but I don't
totally know that it wasn't real because
I've never been to a real truffle hunt
either right at a time was at the S and
it was getting dark right yeah it was we
probably showed up late
freezing maybe hours later question we
were hours yeah it was like it was a 100
foot course where they found all these
truffles the second they started the
adventure so it seemed pretty yeah but
that was fine we were all exhausted so
we're like thank you thank you for
making this yes because otherwise you
got your unexpected joke because when
you had conceived of this bit that
wasn't where you thought the comedy
would be but I'm curious where did you
see that bit going I'm going to defer to
anyone else on that question I don't
remember it was surreal it was weird and
surreal and my favorite one of my
favorite uh parts of the whole trip I
know I know but then it goes right into
the wine which is yes oh my goodness you
guys were already a little punch drunk
and then you went into the wine tasting
and it was really so the wine tastes
unraveled uh was just complete chaos or
at least it felt like it there was the
amount of laughing coming from behind
the camera yes I guess we're used now
that we shoot stuff without an audience
and you hear a lot of our crew laughing
more often but back then I guess you
didn't hear it as much but um
what typically will make me laugh uh is
if I hear someone else laughing that's
like my trigger it happened with Pierre
Bernard and our Thanksgiving remote like
many years ago you had this like
cackling laugh that would get me and in
that case it was you and um Ruthie again
took this behind the scene video which
was posted on the social media and she I
guess was standing right next to you and
you could just hear the amount of
laughing um it was the laughing behind
the camera that set me oh wow and it
just I think they were all left it felt
it felt like just chaos and I felt uh
like it was falling apart and it turns
out it ended up being great yeah I do
remember there was an early screaming of
that remote which again is the first
time I see this where that part was not
present in the screening I think one of
the first versions you took out the part
where we were laughing and the chaos
happened and um and then it got put back
in in retrospect it's it's probably my
favorite part of the that room yeah oh
great it's a good one yeah I think
because we hadn't had it it really
almost
I didn't know if it was going to break
the fourth wall of the show to have you
know it it made it feel like oh are they
breaking character here like oh it does
it make you think too much about whether
it's all kind of staged but no I mean
it's just that's that was the reality at
the moment yeah we went back and forth
on it and then it was just like well
it's really it's just really it's funny
to watch people that trumped every the
idea that oh you know you're I and also
we seeing both of you laughing together
is so rare yeah it is yes it's nice to
see you having fun together too because
as much as Conan shits on you and these
remotes it's you know you want to also
see that you're maybe having fun but
that was also YouTube really going
exchanging equal punches so I think
that's awesome you two just started
cracking up it was almost like it was
something else so everybody's laughing
you mentioned except for one person
I don't think she was allowed to laugh I
don't think she knew what was going on
we had to stop yeah and she's like is
this but that's like she was worried I
thought you we were laughing at the wine
at all and that's kind of why I was
laughing because it was so awkward yeah
right it was awkward yeah so but we we
had to say oh my God no they're making
fun of each other yes yes uh yeah I
enter I could be wrong I interpreted it
as she was personally cool and hip
um but she was there to represent her
company which was a very prestigious
wine around Tuscany going right
Generations right and um there might be
expectations on her to present a certain
image and then certainly this is
devolving into chaos so she's you know
feeling responsible somehow but uh
nevertheless at the there was an
interview with her after and with a Wine
magazine after this aired I don't even
know if you guys had seen no I never
mentioned it but she kind of said as
much she said I thought it was great and
I love to see people having fun but of
course you know we're a professional
operation yeah yeah all right that's
good so you haven't been banned from the
first yeah I certainly hope can I just
why were you scraping the bottom of the
wine glass on the table that seems crazy
I I've never seen anyone do that before
you've never seen anyone aerate a glass
of wine
but not scratching it along a table well
I'm not responsible for the surfaces
present in the winery all I know is that
I want to add oxygen to my wine before I
drink it before I smell it and they
chose to have a stone countertop it's as
simple as that
don't hold it that's annoying
that's annoying me
does it smell good or not excuse me
I will cut your goddamn hand off
that is annoying stop it I'm totally
with Jordan on this one
sweetie loves metal on metal oh man
metal on glass glass on Stone Shale I'm
sorry I don't need to jump ahead but it
just occurred to me because you were
talking about the concept of someone
laughing setting someone else off we had
this crazy experience on a train this is
much later right and
um it was it was a shot as a behind the
scenes thing Aaron Blair uh was shooting
something or something yeah yeah with
his phone and uh it was a similar
situation where we just devolved into
like some kind of laughing fit and
um when we got back uh again I didn't
see any of this footage but I heard this
land your office was across the hall for
me at the time I heard this laughing
coming from your you will laugh
hysterically I feel like I caught you
laughing hysterically screaming footage
as well and um it's that concept of
seeing people laughing that makes you as
a viewer laugh and what were you
laughing at that was a discussion about
30 days yes that's right you know that
that came up uh again unplanned but it
was just an organic evolution
yeah
I'd like to wash it off with soap and
water
they said this will take care of your
problems
what
get in close on him
I'd say maybe I'll go wash it with soap
and water instead
sure
[Music]
she's frightening me
Oh no you're having a meltdown
talking about a bidet
it's expensive why is that
I'm enjoying my time with you
[Music]
yeah I'm scared of you
freak would Frank's getting ready you
love poopies they they crack you up I
guess if you're good I like any joke I
like the good ones and you know
sometimes doody make you laugh no Duty
no poo poo no
dookie now everyone else is left you
know often it's like again I don't you
know I really don't want to jump ahead
but that's cool we're having a real
conversation the thing about Japan was
not the fact that we were discussing
human soil it was the fact that we were
discussing human soil with a very like
straight face Japanese professional
expert from Toto
yeah and it was his reactions or lack
thereof he was very he was dressed in a
suit the way he held himself was very
dignified he had honor he was a man of
honor and he was representing his
honorable products okay and the fact
that these conversations were taking
place in his presence and questions
that's what got me so it's the contract
you were a child you could not stop
laughing you were well you know once you
break the seal right you know that's it
yeah then let the diarrhea flow why do
you like uh scatological humor so much
does it go back to something with your
parent with your mom you know who are we
to like analyze the the reason why
things make us laugh I mean there's you
know there's a lot a lot of it is a lot
of it is the contrast of a certain type
of humor in an otherwise dignified
situation right the fact that you know
where we were a professional show
ostensibly and you know Conan had it was
a legend in comedy he was highly
educated you know this goes back to that
road trip where he was playing um the
fart noise the release of human gas and
uh again given his education and his
stature and comedy he's not someone that
would usually be reduced to that kind of
humor you know he's very sophisticated
in his comedy and the fact that that's
what it turns out he's a man yeah well
that's what kind of gets me
you're not laughing about the poop jokes
now because
this is not a dignified I don't feel it
I don't okay
there's no contract to back it up yeah
so yes you got us up to we're we're on
the train to Naples we actually took the
train which I thought was fun because I
think that's we were in a lot of vans so
it's nice yeah
that's an important part of travel in
Europe
um and then we went to Naples
that's right which is great it happened
in Naples right which I saw that
building in my did you watch my
brilliant friends yes yeah I recognized
it immediately I said we were there oh
one we also saw Cortona was in
succession wasn't it oh yeah oh right
right right yes yes yes it's a gritty
Town that's one of the things I love
about it when I go I actually stay in
the grittiest neighborhood Club dekumani
where all the pizzerias are which is
what kind of looks like Gotham City
there are these like cobblestone streets
and there are the clotheslines hung up
across the street and we shot a lot
there um yeah I loved that that's and
people kind of can communicate between
buildings and there's yeah it's like you
know your neighbors on the other side at
your level yeah there was a lot of that
um we stayed in a strange hotel in
Naples I remember that which was it was
weird that was another reason why I was
self-conscious about having dragged
everyone to Naples the hotel was not
great and just I felt like something
good needed to happen I love that Jordan
got to experience this because we feel
this on travel shows yeah
I fought for this and now yes these
truffle dogs better you know it's turned
something up since you bring that up
it's worth saying you know I've done
many different segments over the years
and we we have many we had many riders
uh let 1315 on average I guess is that
fair to say yeah sure and you know they
were all uh great they all had a certain
standard but there were some that I felt
were better suited towards the segments
with me just because for whatever reason
their humor was was more um
you know relative to the type of stuff
we were doing and one of the great
things about shooting these travel shows
is you kind of you get the A Team it's
like you know at that point Sweeney I
think was even retired from the day to
day there was a strange situation with
you I don't know if you guys are ever
there was this one there was one day
where the entire staff got an email from
you saying you may have heard I'm
leaving I never heard you were leaving
uh and it said Matt O'Brien will be
taking over as head writer but I I'm not
leaving I'm staying on board for
Consulting work and it was at first I
thought it was a joke is this a bit like
and I moved into his office which was
better decorated than anyone else's
office it had like this crazy plush and
you had the song called Stalin is that
how you pronounce it Stalin's yeah yeah
you had it was a very strange situation
anyway you were like Elite you became
like royalty in that moment yeah it was
strange at all okay we started doing the
travel show yes and I was still the head
writer that I would we'd be like in we'd
we'd be in a you know Armenia and like
we'd finish shooting all day and then I
had to go and read everything
so it makes sense I guess it was the way
you announced it there's the way but
regardless you were elevated how was I
supposed to announce my my perception I
was elevated to some sort of uh deity or
God yeah and the fact that I now had the
potential to shoot with you for a week
where I knew you were going to be the
one editing these bits and you you can
see them gave me a lot of confidence
like oh this is probably gonna be good
it's like it's like sure whatever you
get to work with a deity
and it looks great on your resume look
at the Pope's resume it's kind of like
you know every writer should should
perform equally but you know we're human
beings right it's like when you go to
the deli counter like yes they should
all be able to slice your prosciutto
like equally thin but then there's like
the one guy that's like no no you can't
slice it below a one or it'll shred and
you're like that's telling what you're
telling me this like I know Prosciutto
de Panama incredibly well right right so
you were like the deli Center that knew
how to slice for shooting now I can
relate to you and you are the prosciutto
I started the pursuit though
I worked at a deli the amp Deli okay I
mean I know it's a pain to slice thing
yeah when you have to slice thin there
are more slices for given right right
you're talking about a half pound of
meat it's more work it's more work
that's the thing and I think I think you
have to go slower when you're super thin
and you don't want to shred you need to
push the meat into the blade you need a
sharp blade absolutely there's a lot
more involved I understand it's more
work and I'm happy to you know
acknowledge the person's work but like
to make up a scientific reason why it's
not possible to slice something that
thin to me right it's not it's not the
right way to approach it how do you deal
with a thickly sliced prosciutto well if
I see if I see that the result I'm
getting as he's slicing or she is is not
uh thin enough I'll just abort I'll just
say I'll just take a tenth of a pound
instead of a half you don't you don't
try it wow you just I'll go somewhere
else there's a there's a well-known
National supermarket chain high-end
Ralphs well Whole Foods who wants to say
their name uh but they don't believe in
partial Foods let's say so they so
there's a guy there's one guy I was
there's a there are two guys working
there's the guy in the deli and then
there's the guy at the sandwich I think
he supervises the deli sometimes he'll
jump in but you're just talking about
one branch of Whole Foods location but
no I've encountered this at multiple
locations I'm just saying if you're
there's a lot of Art in slicing meat I
agree okay like have you ever seen a guy
that slices locks in New York like I
went to this place say Dells which is
known for their smoked salmon it's uh or
I don't even think it's smokes so it's
not lox but one day they were not
selling the salmon and I said why can't
I get the salmon I was visiting I wanted
to take some home and they said because
the guy that slices it is out sick
there's only one guy that knows how to
slice it the right way because it's an
art I'm just saying slicing meat is an
art yes and I think so you're referring
to Whole Foods expecting an artist to
slice your prosciutto any any
establishment that carries Prosciutto de
Parma it's like 26 dollars a pound
um is going to be a high-end
establishment and yes I would assume if
you're going to be a deli slicer at a
high-end establishment meant you one of
the things you will know if not the
primary thing you will know is how to
slice meat thin enough that it won't
Shred again and and the guy the
supervisor guy said to me oh you can't
uh slice prosciutto under a one Earl
shred I thought he was saying oh the
only way to have prosciutto is thin
don't worry you can't we would never
slice it thick but no he was telling and
the guy actually knew who I the other
guy knew who I was because he said to me
after he's like I love uh I love your
work so he's I don't know you from the
your complaints to them no that's what I
thought no uh this guy they have your
picture about it oh this no he
knew he knew uh I guess he had seen some
of the bits the ones we're talking about
right now and then he's hearing this guy
right lecture me that you cannot cut
prosciutto then and again this is an
expensive product so he he said he
actually gave me the I got you he's like
I got it and he did a great job and now
he doesn't work that he usually works in
the back in the kitchen so I was just
there and you're gonna get the other guy
and and one time I saw the good guy in
the aisles and I said hey man I never
see you there and he's like just ask for
me I'm in the kitchen I don't know why
we're discussing this for this length
I got my answer